c'est pas toujours facile de regarder en
arrière et de voir ce qu'on a fait il ya
même des fois où ça pique mais vraiment
et je vais vous montrer quelques
exemples mais juste après l'intro salut
les gens derrière l'écran c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique moi encore je
suis comme à chaque fois ravi de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle vidéo comme
aujourd'hui on va parler vidéo montage
cadrage technique tout ça si c'est
quelque chose qui vous intéresse vous
pouvez envisager de cliquer sur le petit
bouton s'abonner qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo est aujourd'hui
je vais vous parler de cinq choses mais
un hat trick de plus parce que je sens
qu'il va y avoir de l'inspiration en
cours de route cinq choses que je
faisais avant quand je faisais des
vidéos des vidéos pro ou des vidéos
youtube et que aujourd'hui je regarde
d'un oeil totalement différent en me
disant pourquoi tu faisais ça et
pourquoi qu'est ce que tu vois qu est ce
qu est ce qui s'est passé dans ta vie
pour que tu en arrives à sa non
j'exagère et puis il faut bien sûr
assumer ses débuts ainsi on n'avait pas
commencé quelque part on n'aurait pas
fait d'erreur et donc on n'aurait pas
progressé et tout et tout mais n'empêche
qu'aujourd'hui avec l'expérience que
j'ai acquise il ya plein de choses que
je ferais sûrement différemment
certaines choses que je ne referai
probablement pas alors petit disclaimer
avant toute chose on va parler ici
d'opinion et de goût donc ça m'est
personnelle et j'ai bien évidemment pas
la prétention de détenir la vérité sur
ce qu'il faudrait ou ne faudrait pas
faire si jamais c'est des choses que
vous faites vous peut-être que ça vous
fera réfléchir sur l'intérêt que vous y
porter mais peut-être aussi que ça a du
sens dans vos vidéos bref y'a pas de
mauvaises techniques et pas de mauvaise
façon de faire il ya juste des goûts et
des couleurs et des appréciations donc
cette vidéo n'est pas une critique de
certaines techniques mais juste un avis
personnel sur ce que moi je faisais
avant et qui aujourd'hui a tendance à me
saouler un petit peu c'est donc parti
pour ce top 5 des choses que je faisais
avant et que aujourd'hui je ne supporte
plus alors la première chose c'est
quelque chose que je faisais énormément
avant et qui m'a beaucoup servi
mais aujourd'hui c'est un truc qui me
saoule prodigieusement essaie d'aller
filmer sans but alors le nom rappelle au
tout début quand j'ai commencé je
partais quasiment tous les soirs
filmé dans ma ville des trucs voilà s'il
ya des choses faire des tests et ça m'a
énormément un prix parce que c'était le
moment où
justement je testais mes réglages de
boîtiers j'ai essayé de faire des choses
un petit peu artistique ou pas ça me
permettait aussi de visualiser le rendu
de certaines focal bref ça m'a quand
même beaucoup aidé sauf qu'aujourd'hui
ça m'arrive encore de temps en temps
juste voilà pour me détendre de prendre
mon appareil et d'aller filmer sans but
et je m'emmerde prodigieusement parce
que ben j'ai pas de sujet et j'ai pas
d'histoire alors vous allez me dire tu
peux très bien la trouver
oui alors le truc c'est que bah ça peut
venir comme ça peut pas venir tout
dépend de plein de choses et c'est pas
toujours évident de faire une petite
histoire à partir de rien juste quand on
a une heure à tuer ça reste sympa à
faire quand on a des tests et des
réglages a essayé mais aujourd'hui je
préfère quand même les choses un petit
peu plus construites les choses où il ya
un scénario les choses où j'ai quelque
chose de cadrer quelque chose où je sais
à peu près ce que je veux raconter que
de partir à l'aventuré on va dire sans
trop savoir ce que je vais faire parce
que vu qu'aujourd'hui j'ai fait des
vidéos qui était beaucoup plus scénarisé
voire même très scénarisé quand je vois
le résultat de ce que je fais entre
guillemets un petit peu à la hache
ça me plaît beaucoup moins il n'empêche
que comme je voulais dit ça m'a quand
même beaucoup aidé au début même si je
le fais plus aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose que je regrette absolument pas
d'avoir fait deuxième chose que je ne
fais plus du tout et qui était plutôt
pour le coup une erreur de ma part c'est
utiliser une balance des blancs
automatique en permanence alors la
balance des blancs au tout début j'ai
commencé c'était un concept un petit peu
floue pour moi pour moi le blanc c'était
blanc et je comprenais pas trop comment
ça marche et cette histoire là en
automatique ça marche est relativement
bien mais ça c'était parce que je
filmais la plupart du temps en extérieur
et la balance des blancs automatique en
extérieur sur les boîtiers que j'ai eu
jusqu'à présent et s'est rarement trompé
c'était assez juste il y avait peu de
décalage le problème s'est vite posée
quand j'ai commencé à filmer des choses
en intérieur avec des lumières
artificielles avec des lumières que je
contrôlais pas forcément ou des basses
lumières et là forcément la balance des
blancs
elle a tendance à déconner un petit peu
je me suis très souvent retrouvés avec
des plans pas ruiner mais pas loin
à essayer de rattraper un petit peu la
balance des blancs et aujourd'hui c'est
un truc qui me saute directement aux
yeux une balance des blancs un petit peu
recalés un petit peu rattrapé je le vois
direct ce soit dans mes vidéos ou dans
des vidéos que je vois passer et ça me
voilà ça me titille un petit peu ça ne
gâche un petit peu mon plaisir de
regarder la vidéo de me dire elle à la
balance des blancs et eu comme qui
dirait une petite couille dans le potage
non non ça se voit qu'on a essayé de la
rattraper mais voilà aujourd'hui ce que
je fais c'est que j'utilise encore
parfois la balance des blancs
automatique quand j'ai pas forcément le
temps de la règle et puis que je suis en
extérieur avec je sais que ça marche
relativement bien mais dès que je suis
sur les tournages bouger un petit peu
plus le temps où il ya des éclairages où
il ya des choses comme ça ben là je
prends le temps quand même de faire ma
balance des blancs ou d'utiliser les
préceptes de balance des blancs qui
marche la plupart du temps sur mon
boitier le troisième truc c'est quelque
chose que j'ai fait et limite si je
lance une vidéo et que je vois ça au
début ça me donne presque envie de ne
pas regarder la suite parce que ça ne me
donne déjà une petite idée de ce qu'il
va y avoir après c'est ce qu'on appelle
les open up avec les bandes noires qui
s'écartent comme ça et qui viennent
dévoiler un petit peu là c'est alors ça
ça fait partie des choses qui sont pas
mauvaises du tout c'est une façon
d'ouvrir un début de seine qui est tout
à fait en table le problème c'est qu'on
l'a énormément vue et comme pour tous en
fait on a tendance à se lasser un petit
peu c'est un petit peu comme les
transitions smoothing qu'on a vu 2
milliard de fois
le problème avec ça c'est que souvent
c'est utiliser sans but réel juste pas
effet de mode et je les fais moi aussi
donc je fais un gros mea culpa là dessus
c'est une erreur que j'ai faite je
continue sûrement à faire encore plein
d'erreurs mais j'essaie de les corriger
au fur et à mesure et vraiment ça c'est
un truc à mon avis et ça ça n'engage que
moi je pense que si vous aviez
l'habitude de le faire pourquoi pas très
bien il faut pas regretter ce qu'on a
fait mais peut-être que il ya des façons
de démarrer d'ouvrir une vidéo peut-être
différent qui vont nous permettre de
sortir un petit peu plus du lot qu'en
faisant cette petite technique
sympathique au demeurant mais un petit
peu dépassé et les smoothies zoom non
info ça par contre plus jamais plus
jamais de smooth où je les fais vous
l'avez fait on se met d'accord pour pu
le faire vous et moi ok deal entre nous
un autre défaut que j'ai eu et que j'ai
corrigé plutôt récemment c'est le flat
trop flatteuses m'explique quand on veut
faire de la colo il est recommandé de
filmer dans les profils qu'on appelle
flat voire même du log c'est à dire des
profils très délavé on a beaucoup parlé
sur cette chaîne déjà je vais pas vous
refaire un laïus là dessus le problème
quand je regarde d'anciennes vidéos j'ai
faite c'est que bah ouais ok j'ai
appliqué ce qu'on me disait un jeu filmé
en flat très bien je collais une lutte
par dessus et puis voilà j'étais content
sauf que j'allais oublier une étape un
petit peu crucial qui était l'étape de
la correction colorimétrique parce qu'un
profil flatte ou blogs
ben si on cale une lutte qui est étudié
pour le profil en question ok ça passe
mais je me rends compte que mes noir par
exemple était encore très délavé malgré
le traitement que j'avais appliqué
dessus et aujourd'hui mes goûts ont un
petit peu changé j'ai tendance à
préférer une image plus contrastée
j'ai tendance à vraiment baisser mais
noir a monté un petit peu mais autre
lumière et le résultat je trouve qu'il a
un petit peu plus de caractère
au final je me rends compte que j'avais
tendance à pas vouloir rendre menwar
vraiment noir et en fait finalement je
me dis que c'est pas fidèle spécialement
à la réalité ça donne pas forcément un
look plus signer et que ben finalement
une image contrastée peut avoir un look
tout aussi sympa qu'une image un peu
trop flat et d'ailleurs je me suis même
mis à utiliser un profil qui est
toujours un peu flatte mais beaucoup
moins que ce que j'utilisais avant parce
que je me dis que dans tous les cas si
je dois filmer en flat et rebaisser tous
les noirs et remontaient les plumes hier
autant le faire dans le boîtier à minima
pas complètement parce que je veux
garder de la latitude
mais autant le faire le plus simplement
possible quatrième chose et là ça va
faire un petit peu mal parce que je les
ai énormément fait et je le fais encore
j'essaie de m'améliorer mais je le fais
encore c'est utiliser le slow motion à
outrance
alors le slow motion ça donne des effets
hyper stylé à plein de choses c'est
vraiment quelque chose que j'aime
beaucoup voir dans tous les cas mais je
me suis quand même rendu compte que
au final sur certaines vidéos que
j'avais produite il y avait quasiment
que ça et que malgré tous les effets de
transition que je pouvais en rajouter et
que malgré les rames de vélocité sens ne
parlera juste après ben ça quand même ça
a pété un petit peu le rythme et que
l'alternance entre la vitesse réelle et
du slow motion c'est quand même beaucoup
mieux voire même privilégié la vitesse
réelle plutôt que le slow motion c'est
beaucoup plus difficile parce que
forcément quand on filme à 100 images
par seconde on a un plan qu'on peut
rallonger énormément et remplir un petit
peu si on a besoin des tirs et un petit
peu son montage
même si c'est pas la meilleure chose à
faire alors que quand on filme en 25
images par seconde est pas forcément on
a moins de latitude on a des
tremblements qui vont se voir un peu
plus tous les petits défauts qu'on va
pouvoir masquer facilement avec le slow
motion en vitesse réelle ça va être un
petit peu plus technique alors je vais
pas abandonner le slow motion pour
autant et j'espère que personne ne le
fera non plus parce que ça donne des
choses très joli quand c'est à propos
mais aujourd'hui quand je regarde
certaines vidéos que j'ai fait je me dis
ouais tu t'es quand même pas trop fait
chier et y aller comme un gros bourrin
slow motion slow motion slow motion ça
c'est donc quelque chose qui aujourd'hui
alors c'est pas que je le supporte plus
parce que je l'utilisé encore et il ya
des moments comme je vous le disais où
j'aime beaucoup ça mais j'essaie quand
même de moins de fer et le point un
petit peu lié à celui-là qu'on va
rajouter on va pas dire que c'est un
point entier mais c'est l'erreur de
vélocité aussi j'en fais encore de temps
en temps mais c'est un peu comme les
smoothies sommes tous qu'on le disait
avant c'est quand même quelque chose
qu'on a beaucoup vu enfin la dernière
chose que je faisais avant et que je
fais plus trop aujourd'hui c'est que
avant je me concentrais sur l'aspect
technique sur des choses compliquées je
pensais transition je pensais je pense
et où je pense et musique et aujourd'hui
j'ai tendance à préférer des choses un
peu plus simple pas forcément moins de
travail et bien au contraire mais
aujourd'hui j'ai plus envie de
privilégier des choses comme le cadrage
comme la lumière le storytelling
bref toutes ces choses là qui sont pas
forcément des choses qu'on va voir où
sur lesquelles on va pouvoir faire un
tuto technique sur final cut ou sur
première mais des choses qui vont donner
un côté je trouve un peu plus classe aux
vidéos un peu moins et youtube alors je
ne renie pas du tout où youtube j'ai
démarré mais vidéo en apprenant sur
youtube donc j'ai eu beaucoup
d'influencé de youtuber anglo saxons
français et j'ai vu plein de choses que
aujourd'hui encore je trouve
très réussi mais aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de me diriger par quelque chose
peut-être ne peut plus poser peut-être
que c'est l'âge qui fait ça aussi mais
toutes ces choses que je faisais avant
forcément sur youtube je les garde je
sais les faire encore aujourd'hui mais
je vais vraiment les utiliser si
j'estime que ça a un sens et moins par
effet de mode parce que ça vient du fait
que aujourd'hui je pense que je regarde
les vidéos que ce soient des films que
ce soit des vidéos sur youtube ce soit
des séries avec un oeil un petit peu
différent et que j'ai décortique un peu
tout et que encore aujourd'hui
j'apprends des choses incroyables juste
en regardant un film en me disant mais
whaou
le cadrage de cette scène est juste
extraordinaire où l'éclairage dans cette
scène est juste merveilleux comment
comment le réalisateur il a fait ce truc
là
comment moi je peux le faire aujourd'hui
c'est aujourd'hui un petit peu ce qui va
me me titiller ses problèmes en plus de
ces choses là qu'on va parler sur cette
chaîne dans les mois et années à venir
puisque ben je pense que on est d'accord
pour se dire que la partie youtube on a
fait un petit peu le tour bien que il y
aura peut-être des choses intéressantes
à voir quand même de ce côté là par la
suite mais aujourd'hui voilà c'est plus
ça qui me botte et ses plus de ça que
j'ai envie de parler sur la chaîne et si
vous êtes d'accord avec ça ben rien ne
vous empêche de mettre le coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à me dire en commentaire
vous quelles sont les choses que vous
faisiez avant et qui aujourd'hui vous
sortent par le nez ça m'intéresse aussi
puis - les amis je vous dis comme à
chaque fois rester curieux et à très
bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
et pour ceux qui restent jusqu'à la fin
la nouvelle formation arrive bientôt 80
vidéos a tourné pour cette formation
c'est juste énorme je vais préparer un
truc mais de malades